after nearly three months of diplomacy a
rare breakthrough and a moment of hope
in istanbul
despite refusing to sit at the same
table to sign the document an unlikely
agreement between the two warring
parties
[Applause]
brokered by turkey and the united
nations it should allow grain to leave
ukrainian ports
[Applause]
it's an unprecedented agreement between
two parties engaged in bloody conflict
the beacon of hope on the black sea is
shining bright today
thanks to the collective efforts of so
many
in these trying and turbulent times for
the region and all globe
let that beacon guide the way towards
easing human suffering and securing
peace
ukraine is known as the bread basket of
europe for good reason but the war here
has destroyed this country's ability to
feed much of the world
the fields have been sown but getting
these crops out of the country has been
impossible until now
the agreement to navigate safe passage
through russia's blockade of the black
sea it's hoped will allow grain to be
exported again to near pre-war levels
the silos here in the port city of
odessa are full and another harvest is
on its way
farmers are hopeful this deal will work
we can still save a lot i mean we still
will be doing major steps back in the
development of ukraine in the
development of ukrainian agriculture but
i mean if if the ports open now then and
you know we can
be yeah we can still recover a lot but
um
yeah i'm still skeptical
[Music]
millions of people around the world
particularly in the global south are
also dependent on ukraine's brain
and the specter of famine and a
worsening migration crisis is looming
the agreement is known as the black sea
initiative but perhaps a better way of
looking at it is as a really focused
ceasefire at sea
but signing a document is one thing
putting it into practice is another when
ukraine and russia are still locked in
an extremely bitter war which shows no
sign of ending
and trust is a commodity that is still
extremely scarce as russia and ukraine
continue to trade blows
these pictures show the devastation of a
russian attack on a school in the
ukrainian city of kramertorsk there is
still then much that could go wrong with
this agreement which involves strong
cooperation monitoring and checks from
both sides
these ships will have to be cleared
uh that they don't have explosives that
there isn't going to be
mines uh place in
the black sea that would blow up a ship
we have all of these
issues that have to be implemented but
certainly this is a big achievement it's
a great effort
for now this is a big win for diplomacy
and senior officials within the united
nations hope grain will sail from
ukraine within the next couple of weeks
but if this agreement fails it will
exacerbate a global cost of living
crisis that's already causing
catastrophic food shortages in some of
the poorest parts of the world
alex rossi sky news denipro